Along with all the other changes
that you've been making in the app,
now that you know who the owner is,
you can start implementing some
rudimentary premissioning.
For example,
there are some things in the app
that only the owner of
a list should be able to do.
I'll start with two pretty simple ones.
Only the owner of a list should
be able to edit the list name,
and only the owner of a list should
be able to remove that list.
Now if the person looking at that
list isn't the owner of the list,
they shouldn't even have the option
to be able to do these things.
You know who's logged in,
and you should be able to grab
list data for the database.
So, could you write the code that will
only show these options if the user is
the owner of the list?
I'll send over the full spec now.
Take a look.